and they win both those games to make
those playoffs that counts as a series
because those are serious games not
counters those are our playoffs the nba
does not even count it as the playoffs
those stats don't exist they go off into
like stat purgatory
i was wondering
they don't it's like it never happens
they need to have like just a specific
play so i'll we're going to be using by
the way some nba dunk judges grading and
when you first started i was going nine
and then you gave a qualifier and i made
it an eight and then you said the
playoff was a series and i ended on a
series of playoff games i don't want on
this show takes where people are like if
everybody's healthy and lebron drops 40
a game come on and i'm just an optimist
so that very well may not happen and we
may be in cancun a little earlier than
expected but when did deandre ayton have
a chain like that baller wow
uh win a playoff series if they i'll say
what and and i i want all of these takes
to be remembered so that if it happens i
want to be able to play this clip
afterwards and give you your flowers
just like i want flowers i really know
very well
good and damn well that nba twitter is
watching this they have clipped off that
clip and they will run it yeah
mainly if some bad things happen if good
things happen they'll forget oh yeah
mickey mouse ring bubble whatever
whatever the terminology would be
whatever the new lebron nickname will be
right you're 19 we've never seen
anything like it that's just me
mickey
and those are funny yeah yeah but so is
the ring and if your team didn't make
the bubble how are you talking about the
bubbles the thing i always say wait
great point why didn't you win the
bubble championship if it was so easy oh
i felt like the suns were second place
because they went 8-0 but didn't play uh
so
you might think that you're being a
little spicy
apparently somebody was even spicier
than you and is doubling down on your
take let's get a little taste a little
taste
lebron and a.d have not lost the playoff
series together and it's not gonna
happen this year they dominated in 2020
and they'll dominate again this year the
lakers roster problems are overblown the
peripheral pieces don't matter as much
as the superstars and lebron and anthony
davis are still the best duo in the
western conference
okay
i am going to say originality
7 8
energy
to me that energy was like a 6.
i feel like that was a 10 for him like i
feel like that was a lot of energy for
him
so i'm gonna give that take
uh
that that to me i'm gonna be a hard
judger because i don't like the dung
contest when they go too high early on
that's a five to me
you're bringing up old statistics you're
you're not giving me anything new
um and also
i just i don't i don't agree with it but
i feel like you have a meme queued up
meme how do you guys know all this
well because i i mean
i want that in my ear too yeah i do have
a meme
i'm obviously delusional
we're gonna go jerry springer that's
facts that's facts now he's he's capping
because i think what is he saying when
they're both been healthy because they
literally lost to the sons last year
obviously the hammy gave out on a.d
we'll see though it's just hard you're
right he was missing an important fact
when healthy when healthy there's nobody
that is not something that you can ever
bank on it's just tough there's been a
lot going on lebron was getting in that
super bowl like most of us were super
weak was turnt up
it's hard i just don't know and i just
don't want to see him go out like this
it's year 19. i was hoping that he'd be
able to only play like 50 games this
year conserve his body get ready for the
postseason every time he drops a new 25
point game and they lose i don't get
happy about that i'm just like dog like
i love that meme that i saw recently
kid from akron hashtag chasing kareem so
good
so good um
if i were how spicy would this take be
that kcp should have won the uh finals
mvp i had memes for that and i'm sure
your crackpot staff will find them but
uh yeah i had memes with that how he was
looking at the finals mvp trophy don't
think so okay lebron's smart like lebron
knows like bubble you know he's it's
funny everybody else in the bubble like
you heard all these stories about people
getting mentally frazzled whatever like
lebron grew up in akron in the hood like
yeah like what are you talking about i
get to stay at disneyland for a month
what about how spicy was lebron's take
that the bubble championship was the
greatest championship of all time
because it was the hardest very accurate
no home games
disney world janky rooms
think about like javale mcgee's room
that he got like a standard room that we
would get somewhere this man's like
seven foot one having to put two double
beds the two janky double bed where you
slide in between the middle like a
sandwich like a po boy that zion was
eating on the every morning someone's
like room service and he's like leave me
alone
um hot sauce no seasonings like what are
we talking about other spicy uh takes
that i'm seeing in the app right now
uh
capo got to juice 23.
you said that one more time for me so i
got in trouble on tnt last night because
i said balling and then shaq was like
did you just pronounce the g
capo got the juice
does kappa really have the juice though
and what kind of juice is it well it's
cranberry mango healthy clippers oh it
says healthy clippers in the western
conference i'll assume that he wrote
finals but that's not a bad take i
should have read that take that was a
bad take baishon trae young is a
fraudulent superstar who doesn't impact
winning
that is spicy well everybody knows
baeshan is a die hard warriors fan and
it clouds his visions a lot and he says
a lot of crazy absurd [ __ ]
gotcha okay there's a bias to that take
give it a one wow okay trey went to the
eastern conference finals last year orca
whale
damian lillard is not a top 75 player of
all time over vince carter and tracy
mcgrady i mean i would say even over to
white and i love damn dan is the man but
you look at a guy like dwight and it's
like what are we doing here like what do
we value
that he doesn't make it chocolate
shoulders um
what are we talking about dwight's
shoulders early in his career were
insane insane i think what's interesting
is there's a few guys anthony davis is
one of those guys where i think that
we're gonna look later and go damn did
we mess that up i think you say that for
the hundred right like and no disrespect
to ads had an amazing career but his
career didn't really take off until he
came to los angeles and obviously he was
doing a lot of great stuff with the
pelicans but i got nervous when they put
his picture up in the middle like i
thought all of a sudden he was gonna be
like what that was like my bad problem
but no i think when you look at those
lists they're more of a popularity
contest and that's the problem if you
play in some of these flyover states and
small market teams you're not going to
get the level of love so right naturally
if you're on the clippers or the the
knicks or whoever you're going to blow
out their their their accomplishments
and then kind of overlook and devalue a
lot of other guys and do you know who
jamal crawford said last night should've
been on top 75 grant hill oh
injury waiver maybe bill walton's on it
that man was injured as hell go on the
legend he's in the announcer hall of
fame okay we're taking too much time
now
we have a final five
five people that sent in 20 second clips
by the way everybody in the br app
that's commenting right now if you want
to be on this next time we will put it
out on twitter we will put it out on
instagram send your best 20 seconds and
that is how you get on this show but we
have five
i have not seen them you have not
all i said to our amazing staff
make sure they're fun and spicy they
could be bad they could be good
first one is about the celtics
who came back big win last night here is
our first submission to take masters
ever on the celtics yo
what's good everybody it's your boy
caleb p jordan and today my topic is why
the celtics will win the chip in the
last 10 games we went 9-1 in that margin
jason tatum has averaged 23.9 before
2022 we in december lost 9 games out of
14. since january 12th we have won 15
games out of 20 and robert williams is
leading nba in offensive rating and
defensive rating if the celtics keep
playing like this we will win the
championship you get the ball jason
starts dribbling buzzer beater
[Laughter]
that was such a turd at the end that i
was not ready for he bricked it he
bricked it okay
let me go back to my scoring originality
one
boston celtics will win the chip
he had multiple camera angles
he brought up statistics originality
boston's winning the championship he
even could have gone as far to say the
advanced analytics of 538 have them at
the highest percentage of 17
i'm gonna give his originality a nine
energy i'm giving him a 10. that was
exactly what i'm looking for what was
his name again uh it's caleb p jordan
he's a legend be on the lookout for him
i think he's like 16 years old i
connected with him did his podcast yes
like last year i'm just like yo dog you
have way too much energy way too small
you're going to be on tv one day so book
that one that's a take that will really
happen spiciness i am going to give that
man boston's healthiest with a chip i'm
gonna give that an eight
that means that my final score for him
in an average
i'm giving him a nine okay so i don't
know do you have memes here what are you
thinking are you what are you thinking
grade wise no yeah that should have just
pulled a meme up while you were talking
whatever you're right i know i'm slow
i'm sorry i was going to give him a 10
for all the things that you mentioned
but the take
gets a zero they're not winning the
championship what are we talking about
here yes
and i'm not a celtics guy either like
celtics
sell the twitter i hate you too you know
that so does that mean your score is a
five
let's give them uh to average the
spiciness and the
the fact that it's not going to happen
he's young i don't want to break his
spirit so i'm going to give him a 7. and
i here i am i was like i'm going to be a
tough judge early on and i'm like 9.
that
caleb p jordan
do you think that he was like i'm gonna
do the michael b jordan and just throw
the p in there he's a the fact that he
missed the shot that's why i was
comfortable with the nine because if he
hit it and he zoomed in on the miss
which means he took multiple shots and
then chose that take yeah form is a
little janky too i will say looks like
you have a broke jumper chief
wow caleb p jordan i just want to
confirm y'all
y'all didn't edit that right he put that
together
he put that together he's talented like
he has like a 13 or 14 year old sister
who's this producer so the whole time i
interviewed him yeah my producer did
this and we came up with this and i was
like who's your producer he finally
brought it on camera oh what's going on
like damn i didn't know like i had a
whole family affair then you started
like oh i got a league so my mom's got
to go drop me off at work so kid works
hard grinds gets his take out i think
he's got a pot out check it out like
he's a legend
all right so i am giving it a nine
and are we adding them up or am i just
giving one
it's like iron chef and josiah gave a
seven so we give caleb out of a possible
20 a 16. which is pretty good that's an
80 percent
it's a b minus he might not make it to
the next round but he can hold his head
high all five of our potential take
masters are watching right now and i
want you to know that we're going to get
down to the final two and we're going to
have kind of a takeoff we're going to do
like a little interview with them at the
end okay but i'm telling you right now
that even though someone might get
higher than a 16 that that that does not
like
caleb could have the highest score does
not mean he's winning we need to talk to
them at the end to make sure that they
have the
intestinal fortitude i think
okay we got the juice let's uh take one
more look at at the moment that we won't
forget from caleb the miss shot one more
time just to really soak it in
oh
it hit the ceiling almost i love it
uh a few more spicy takes snake 35
staying on the celtics robert williams
is a top five pick in a 2018 nba
re-draft too much work i don't remember
who was drafted in 2018. guys we're
literally just doing a simple show not
trying to dig deep into the archives
basketball reference uh max myers tyler
hero is a better scorer than devin
booker
max myers white or black
he's white yeah oh i'm glad you did not
post that uh february 1st to the 28th
because you would have got ridiculed
you're right that is the second
international women's history month that
is a march 2nd
um
okay
now
our second take all i know we haven't
seen it yeah i don't know what it is
it is about the heat
and corindrage so it is very specific
let's hear our second take here on
takemasters one of the biggest stories
that nobody's covering the nba is how
gorn dragons is actually a sleepless
double agent sitting on behalf of the
highest ranking members of miami heat
brass to implode the net season from the
inside hashtag coach chatter where was
going drivers all this time while he was
being traded bought out and resigned in
miami you're telling me he's been miami
this whole time and never had to sit
down with pat riley pat riley wakes up
in the morning and tampers to keep his
teeth white do you think gordon wants to
share the ball with a guy who slapped
the back of the head roll the tape pat
riley has his invisible hand inside the
net's locker room and you can't see it
because it's invisible open your third
eye
wow
so this might be a little older of a
movie reference for some of our viewers
but in the words of billy madison
slow
down gotta slow it down
is it can we slow that down is that
possible
[Music]
and shout out to rage against twit
goran drakic is a sleeper agent
saboteur for the miami heat
let me break down my thinking process
number one
love a take like this
these are my favorite takes that pat
riley because goran dragach was living
in miami is trying to ruin the nets from
the inside out also
i could believe this with pat riley i
can believe that he has a button that
opens the door and then you come in and
he's got another button just in case he
doesn't like you that's going to drop
you into a pit of snakes execute order
66 gorn
second thing i liked i forgot about the
time that goran dragach smacked ben
simmons in the back of the head great
call back good reference and it's not
like that awful 2018 redraft take he did
the work for us he showed us the slap i
really like that third look at him
goran dragach
not only is the name of a sleeper agent
he kind of has the look of it he's the
kind of guy in that mean that he like
puts a little bit of the uh the powder
in your drink and stirs it up but then
forgets and licks it originality
i'm going 10. i haven't heard this i
didn't even i haven't even thought about
this this is great
energy
i like the way he did it i like the
zooming in the speed though i think
that's part of the 22nd rule that we've
established here
i'm gonna take his energy down to an
eight
and the spiciness though
the spiciness is a 10. i screwed myself
on that first one
i really did i want to bring caleb this
is your show you can do whatever you
want
um i'm giving my first 10.
i'm giving my first 10. that's a march
2nd 10.
you could not have given that 10
february 28th
i would just say that
uh
i'm so angry at myself that i did that
in the first one i am you know what
there are no rules here right
my first grade i'm changing the grades
i'm sorry caleb p jordan i i messed up
and i was about to curse i'm i had caleb
originally at a nine
i'm so sorry caleb i love you i'm moving
him down to a six
and i'm taking rage against twit and i'm
making him an eight so that means that
caleb is now a fourteen perfect meme
usage by you guys trying to figure out i
was trying to figure out what he was
saying that first how he sounded like
the micro machines guy i know i'm dating
myself for anybody this is your reaction
this was i was just trying to figure out
what he was talking about yeah but um
i could see that happening though gordon
dragon seems like an honorable man like
pat i'll do this one thing for you but i
think the real thing is that feels like
he's a driving petrified fan obviously
we all were kind of growing up he had us
caring about the nets i was born in new
jersey so he played with steve nash in
phoenix there's
there's some things going on okay so i
wanted a ring i'm giving him an eight
the kd version was much better uh
what is what is your grade how are you
breaking down what we just saw from rage
against so originality definitely 10.
spiciness pen and what's the other one
creativity creativity uh energy energy
[ __ ] he i mean he he was passionate yeah
i can't give him a 10 though
i'm gonna give him a
nine wow okay
that was a big one rage against twit
really proud of you again caleb like
i've talked to you before you're amazing
i'm sorry like i didn't mean to bring
you down so caleb is now at 14 and a
nine and eight is 17 for rage again so
we should make them the two top people
battle off to the death that's what's
gonna happen with their takes with
it's it sporks think it can't hurt but
it can it can definitely do damage wow a
sleeper agent okay that was really good
uh we do have some responses by the way
to the takes thus far to our first guy
jay richard 35 says no shot the celtics
win the chip let alone get to the
eastern conference finals
we get it yeah it's pretty standard
trick van exel
great name if you have a great name on
twitter i will always follow you like uh
trick financial goran draga to secret
agent lmao okay
uh jj taylor 076 nah lefko goron
definitely wants to win a ring with the
nets no way he's a sleeper agent see and
this is what y'all wore in in the the
pics because our take agents our our
takis our take masters they got the
spiciness these are just normal
reactions
uh other hot take here in the the
comment section connor malley maxi is
more important to the sixers than hardin
it's just not true
it's not true i just sometimes wonder
what basketball people are watching
because it's much different than the one
i'm watching
and no disrespect to tyra she's a legend
but this is why i like take masters
because i know that our guys have been
sitting on these takes for a long time
okay
i'm gonna test your your control room if
they have the shot of him in the polo
show when they did the starting lineups
and they didn't even give them a jersey
tyrese maxi yeah okay if they can pull
that up i'll give them 26 seconds
26 seconds i don't think they're gonna
be able to do it but if they have the
shot that i mean they've been incredible
though
they didn't even give him a jersey it
was straight polo
it's legendary but i think that drove
him and gave him that hunger like damn
they didn't even give me a journey they
just grabbed i can't talk about the
sixers anymore because i get way too
excited i know how happy you were when
that deal went down and i think a lot of
people were scratching their heads but
i'm like yo i'm motivated harden
i'm like one guy has had two triple
doubles in the last three weeks the
other guy's been playing twitch for
eight months what are we talking about
here and it's tough when you don't and
this is no knock to ben simmons but when
you don't play at that level you're just
kind of watching everybody else that's
now in mid-season later you're still
trying to get in pre-season form it's a
little tough but not to knock it i think
ben can really come and do some work
he's gonna really help with the
defensive side and give kd some relief
when he comes back
but we'll see so we were talking about
top 75 guys earlier and we were talking
about like people that weren't on the
list god bless you yeah
you're well you're well it's all good
man i can't be in a room and someone
sees this like don't say god bless you
i'm not a heartless person i know you're
holding that sneezing i know you
don't know
just let it go okay we're on the app uh
take
uh
if somebody sneezes on the plane should
you say god bless you or ew gross
the next plane the nasty thing i think
you can do when you're wearing your mask
yeah people that pull their mask down to
sneeze sneeze it's like no you need to
live in that snot bro
your face now live in the sneeze that's
the whole point of this math do not yank
it down to sneeze all over it but take
masters if you have to sneeze is it
respectful to sneeze inside of your
hoodie yeah hoodie shirt or whatever but
i wipe that like everybody thinks i'm a
weirdo cause every time i fly i come
with the clorox bleach wipes i would dap
you up right now over overdo it because
literally the headrest is the dirtiest
part of a plane i used to work with this
company attention we used to do videos
on things like this it's like dirtier
than the toilet wipe down the head
because i think everybody head sweat and
all the nastiness give it a good wipe
down i'll wipe all the buckles down and
everything i wipe it down too wipe me
down um
shoulders knees takes uh so the one guy
that was also down the top 75 klay
thompson yeah apparently this next take
our third take our take masters take
klay thompson take it away
klay thompson is the best shooting guard
in the league and that includes james
harden
second thing the golden state warriors
will make it to the finals this year
versus those new look philadelphia
sixers and clay thompson will outperform
james harden in the nba finals on his
way to his first finals mvp
clay thompson outperfo so he dropped a
triple stack of ticks
that klay thompson is the best shooting
guard in the league
that they will play the sixers in the
finals and that he will outperform james
hard in the finals and win finals mvp
and this is your response i don't know
about that one chief
i'll let you go first since you queued
up the meme this is i love klay thompson
i would have loved to see clay thompson
play with lebron and make that right
decision he did not he stayed with
golden state not playing for two seasons
coming back
bang out bang out first you know first
possession
he's gonna need a little bit of time i
think
next season that the take that may very
well have some legs to it this season's
gonna be a little tough he's still got a
lot a lot of work left to do to get to
back to clay form but i used to always
say too and i mean no not to steph but
clay literally has to guard the best guy
on the defensive side and hit wedders
and if he concentrated on just scoring
like steph does not say he would be at
steph's level but he'd be damn close yes
uh what's your grade
i'm gonna give it
uh oh [ __ ]
is my language
we're in the brf there's no rules
i'm gonna give it a seven it was
egregious but he was confident in his
speaking i think i find that for people
from the bay i don't know if he's from
the bay but they're always just
his his name is f flossy 253. does that
make it he's from the bay probably east
bay if i had to go um
so
i have issues with this one
and
and he played to my uh sixers fandom
but
the first thing that i took away from
that was
energy's a three
this is not the time to be cool
cool does not translate on camera it's
it's this is this is about hot takes
it's not about lukewarm takes or
chilling in the jacuzzi takes hot takes
three energy
also
he said that klay thompson was the best
shooting guard in the league better than
james harden i don't think james
harden's the best shooting guard in the
league who you got like
it's hard there's i don't even know what
positions people play that's that's my
whole thing it's like are we calling i
think james harden has the ball most of
the time i kind of think him as a point
guard half the time look i used to say
back in the day lebron's a point guard
and i used to get roasted people eat me
a lot he initiates the offense literally
look at the textbook definition of what
a point guard and then to turn it a
point forward like no he's not really a
point forward right because he's doing
this consistently so it's really hard to
say
so and then the third i do like the
spiciness the final take
picking a finals match up and then
picking someone that's gonna win the
finals mvp uh do i think that it could
be a warrior sixers finals absolutely
the originality of saying that in his
comeback season clay is going to come
back and win finals mvp that is spicy
that is in my opinion because you think
it's unlikely the spicy meter goes up to
a 10. for me unfortunately the energy
i think it's the east bay like you were
saying brought it down
i gave my guy caleb a six
and i i got it wow
you did change caleb two or six
that means that i got to be the tough
judge and i'm giving it a four whew
and and hey flossie i i appreciate you
putting my six you gotta add one because
his name is philosophy okay i'll give
him a five give give philosophy a five
false philosophy of five what did you
give
what are seven i think
so that's a 12.
not flossy enough not lost enough you
know i'm glad that i'm going to be the
tough judge i i couldn't been the judge
i was giving out nines and tens the
entire time i got to be the a-hole you
got to be the d-wage yeah yeah yeah no
i'm not feeling it but flossy i like the
structure of it i like that you made a
finals i like the spiciness the
spiciness of it but we've had a guy
yelling and screaming and shooting
basketball and then another one trying
to fit a thousand words into 20 seconds
i just like the energy more and i'm an
energy guy never doubt play off clay
though i will say that
and this warrior squad you know get
wiseman back get draymond back
they're gonna be a problem i i would i
would take them over the sun i have no
idea who's coming out of the west
you don't know who's gonna be healthy by
the time we get to that point so when
when there's a report yesterday that
michael porter jr and jamal murray could
be back soon like
man
and then i have to get into was the
bubble reel and i don't want to talk
about that because i know it's going to
upset you but jamal murray in the bubble
was a problem hardest
on donovan mitchell easily the hardest
championship no home games
and everybody's like oh they didn't have
bam and they didn't have who cares why
didn't i i will say that the fact that
tyler hero is going to win sixth man of
the year it is it weird that that almost
validates the lakers championship more
because with tyler here going nuts in
the bubble and then was not good last
year that made me question the lakers
championship more so i feel like lakers
fans should be rooting for tyler hero
more look when you look at that bubble
think about it there was like eight fans
there they were all friends and family
you had to see these people in the hotel
lobby after the game how difficult that
is drop 50 on the dude have to go see
him at the pool afterwards i don't think
it's that difficult it is they're in
your head no home games no travel
lebron's uh you don't need to try these
can't get inflamed neither can anyone
else who had tweaked knees or issues or
anything else going on and for teams
that didn't even make the bubble did you
go to the bubble no okay i'm done they
tried everybody's gonna i don't try to
make me go to like all-star weekend with
no fans in atlanta i'm like you're gonna
send me to the epicenter of the rona
this was pretty i don't know why i
thought you were like really important
in the basketball circles where they
were like we need we need uh josiah
there for the memes i'm not spending two
weeks in a hotel room not doing anything
uh like imagine that i would have went
crazy
yeah glad you all did great job out
there everybody though okay
we started off the show with unintended
zion slander no need for it we don't
know where this take is going it could
be pro zion it could be odin zion no no
don't give me the odin zion zion's been
hurt but when he's played he's
performing
i'm sorry take number four
take masters
so i'm here to tell you that zion
williamson is probably not going to be
playing for the new orleans pelicans
this season or ever again david
griffin's pretty much severed that
relationship is he going to play is he
not going to play jj reddick said that
he's detached and people are knocking
the man for gaining weight but if i
lived in new orleans i would gain weight
too the food is freaking awesome it is
the food is freaking awesome
i have so many thoughts
zion williamson
is not going to be playing for the
pelicans
ever
again
yeah
why would he they didn't even like you
know they're just disrespecting the guy
all right so i'm trying to think about
big first of all big low country
cup
whose idea was it to put zion in a
commercial from this angle
with a mountain dew
and some cheetos
the problem we run into a lot of times
they don't think about the memes they
need to bring me on to consult
okay so big low country
i first of all he he was wearing dwyane
wade's outfit from last night
casual suspenders
on a wednesday afternoon
big low country also complemented the
food in new orleans because it's great
and i like the pitch at the end
man i got jokes and i just can't fire
him off josiah i just can't do it zion
hitting the mountain dew this is one of
my favorite memes
always always timely always thought but
he wants to go to the knicks let him let
him regroup with his crew you got
cameras got rj barrett out there
thibs probably needs to you know
we'll chat
but uh let them go to new york man give
them free and it's like
the thing about i've you know i've been
in new orleans a few times
for who though but apparently that
popeye's is the best popeyes known to
man really and if i was zion i'd be
hitting popeyes if i'm rich
multi-millionaire i'm getting biscuits
i'm turning up
he's eating the beignets
yeah like can you imagine if zion one
time came into practice and there was
like powdered sugar on his jersey and
they were like we know exactly where
that's from um
but if you're the pelicans and you see
that float
like people painted that like they got
together they had like a brainstorming
session like oh let's make one tone on
this jersey remember when the story came
out about their gm playing the piano for
zion
that remember that story that remember
how this started that the pelicans were
trying to win over zion and david
griffin was like
come on man i'm gonna play the piano and
you can chill okay but i gotta focus on
this take let me just see my schedule
originality zion will never play for the
pelicans again
not going that high on originality
because i feel like i've heard this
taken before so i'm going to give
originality a four again i'm the tough
grader uh bigelow country so i apologize
energy my energy was down
and then he hit on the the food is great
and it kind of popped it up i'm gonna
give it a five for energy okay
spiciness
i do think that it is somewhat spicy i
will get a seven so my overall for him
will be
what was the last one again what was
this take klay thompson i gotta give it
a four
i'm a tough judge man
i i gotta be the tough judge here on
take masters i'm giving it a four
i can never read a little country i love
you though man i appreciate you look the
take
we've heard it but he came with it the
food delicious
so he was accurate he was accurate
energy
he definitely perked up like i would too
thinking about gumbo and beignets and
all the beautiful things jambalaya that
new orleans has oysters oh ow
so i wasn't a big oyster guy i wasn't a
big oyster guy till about what he was a
guy serious years ago i was like ooh
doing some oyster shooters like these
are delicious don't chew them if you
don't if you don't look at what you're
eating the same thing with sushi black
people eat raw sushi but just eat it and
enjoy it
don't worry about what you're eating but
i'm gonna give it a five a five giving
him our first single digits a nine uh
one time in the makeup room uh me and
shaq were going back and forth about
whether foods uh
he would call them white people foods i
think you were there that day you you
told me you broke it down and i came in
a little bit late i think that was my
first time ever being here and i would
just say it was just me and shaq being
like jolly ranchers and he'd be like
purple
uh
what was one britney you remember this
well no i'm not going to say that let's
go do it yeah don't risk it all risk it
all for jolly ranchers get out of here
risk it all for watermelon jolly
ranchers
black food or white food risk it all
the bigwigs are watching this this is
awesome but everybody loves watermelon
any other ones
and you you said adam say watermelon no
that is the flav this is like when shaq
put the dreadlocks who said do the
accent and i was like are you trying to
get me canceled like i don't get
anything watermelon related at
restaurants just because like my wife is
the same way i can't order fried chicken
or watermelon
i can't do it even if that's the best
item it started because i said it was
hazelnut cake and he said white people
food i've never even seen a hazelnut
cake before but then he said to me he
goes um
chocolate is chocolate ice cream is a
white people food
it blew my mind black people do not eat
chocolate ice cream i've
you've never gone to a black person's
birthday event wedding funeral whatever
maybe
maybe there's some strawberry in there
too not getting hit strawberry lightly
if the vanilla so the vanilla goes and
wow and we used to do that as kids and i
always wondered like what are we doing
here like why just get the vanilla yeah
it sounds great in principle right three
different ice creams ooh but no nobody's
messing with that chocolate i would love
for there to be like our intermission on
take masters to just be random food
takes and maybe we get shaq to just
record where we guess if he's gonna say
white people food no for sure chocolate
ice cream is a white people food no idea
i really learned that i had no idea but
black people will take vanilla ice cream
and overload it with chocolate syrup it
doesn't make sense but this is the world
we live in wow
you got any other food takes oysters was
a good one oysters what is the worst
food ever
food take black licorice okay it's
sun-dried tomatoes
in college why does it taste like that
21 obviously but the sun doesn't do that
to anything else why is that gigger
shots like no please get that away from
me it's the worst thing i've ever seen
in my life no get it away black licorice
the worst food ever uh greatest food
ever ooh
i'll go first chicken pot pie
wow yep homemade or like the marie
calendar's joint not the marine calendar
no because then you get to like the
bottom crust and you're like i don't
know what chemicals are in this yeah for
sure second place
doritos dude uh
i was at the store yes third place
popcorn yeah popcorn is legit hi josiah
and i are kind of fat that's what you're
learning about everybody knows that
though everybody knows i'll put in work
i'm basically like light skinned and
zion uh but
all right so favorite food peach cobbler
my mom's peach cobblestone
and i can't have the full peaches in
there i need them chopped up and mashed
into more of like yeah because you don't
be like yeah it's the oyster rule yeah
okay don't chew your oysters
vote them doggies
i'm not seeing enough comments in the
app about food takes i want your food
takes in the app
masters we are so we got zion we got
clay we got goran dragach and we got the
celtics which means we are up to our
final take of the submission period this
better be something super duper spicy
it is about the mavericks
the team that knocked off your lakers
last night
that suddenly
jason kidd
former assistant coach of the lakers
when their defense was amazing
is now on the mavericks and their
defense is amazing i hope i didn't steal
the take wait before we roll this take
and i just say one thing it's about
jason kidd's collar when dj uh who's
that corked bathroom ever incredible one
of the most phenomenal things i've ever
seen in social media history but when
the drink spilled at the game and
everybody was wondering if it was tasty
and then they cut the dj mustard once
the ot genesis was with them like just
oh man
clip of jason kidd bumping into the gl
to the cup at rocking to me walk into me
oh my gosh
beautiful what a legend all right here's
our fifth and final take something about
the mavs let's see where they take us i
have a take and it's not a hot one the
dallas mavericks are making to the nba
finals this season
they have all that it takes to make a
deep run with size length athleticism
defense coaching and they have most
importantly they have luca dondas
running the show the west is more
winnable than ever lebron might not even
make the playoffs the western conference
better not sleep on the dallas mavericks
because they're coming for you and
they're going to win
and that was from ryan dre and i will
cut all of the tension with a knife
this is josiah's reaction
can i tell you why i'm giving it a one
play the first two seconds of this play
the first five seconds of that take one
more time
please
i have a take and it's not a hot one and
then cut it off into the nba finals cut
it off this season if you are coming on
to take masters
this is not take self-conscious this is
not take i'm not sure where i'm gonna
settle on this and ryan i know you're
watching you seem like a great guy and i
love you too but you cannot
cut your own take in half by going this
isn't even hot it's not even a good take
i'm gonna say he was nervous he's making
a video he's gonna be on the brf i think
you know what i think what he was trying
to say was
this is gonna happen yeah okay but i i i
couldn't even hear the rest of it he's
confident though so i gotta i gotta
change my score i wasn't gonna go low
and now because i went solo you're gonna
you're gonna coddle him i want people to
like me okay wow you are you're the rant
you're the i'm gonna give it a six but
this is why because it was a good take i
think he shouldn't start it off with
it's not a hot tub yeah i got i got
messed up we should have clipped it off
past that he should have no edit mode
we're doing people who are not my dream
is that somebody forgets to clip the end
of their video and they're like ma
i'm doing a video and like they send it
in by accident he reminds me my dad my
dad does not know how to crop photos or
anything by the way i'm moving it up to
a two i'm moving it to a two i feel bad
ryan it's a spicy take look i was gonna
say if dragons went over to the mavs and
joined luca
potentially possible
but that squad struggled with the lakers
and the lakers
to date have been fairly cooked there
are two teams and oddly enough they both
played last night that my fear is that
they're peaking too early the mavs are
won and the celtics are the other one
where we see this every year you
dominate january february march and then
when april may comes
the rest of the team now the rest of the
teams have kind of seen the film they've
kind of figured you out a little bit and
in the words of ray lewis momentum
is real yeah for sure uh i thought the
grizzlies in there too and no knocking
them they just don't have that that
playoff experience that's necessary
but i'm very scared of what job is going
to be in the next two to three seasons
but i will say to ryan
to ryan's take about the mavericks
if this luca j kidd
relationship is good
lucas 23 years old here is the caller
what an incredible moment of internet
history this was where was it every a
thousand retweets or a hundred retweets
corked bat made the collar bigger and
bigger
so the thing is that fit he's wearing he
used to get that at t.j maxx as a kid
used to come up and be in the clearance
rack it'd always be a size it didn't fit
like a 5x or whatever it may be but a
baller fit like if you wore that fit in
2002 at the club
you were getting numbers and you're
getting hollered at it looking at 2002
fashion like people were like you're
wearing your jersey the correct way nah
turn it around yeah put marshall falk in
the front yeah oh man pele pele
oh
anichi oh so much goodness fat farm oh i
any time you see a dude that's wearing
that
what's your first thought
legend
no i was like man
either he's a time traveler
[Laughter]
or he doesn't have good friends or he
just served a bit i won an academic
velour suit for my birthday
did you hear that baller mrs mrs king
josiah the the velour series back in the
i remember velour first came out and we
were all wearing it and we all felt so
special so before we go let me just get
a few more comment takes from the app
okay we have some food takes this is
going to serve us our intermission
before we announce uh our two that are
there uh
j.i
jid1313 apple pie
is better than strawberry cheesecake
no one said what that yeah but nobody's
ever gonna make that debate like they're
both delicious apple pie isn't my top
three desserts it's top three for you
apple pie
key lime pie oh so you're a key lime guy
i didn't know that right and um
man all desserts
uh
i don't know ice cream okay for sure
you gotta go off key the yellow cake
with the chocolate frosting oh
strawberry shortcake also delicious
better than cheesecake i'll say
and peach cobbler got it like yeah okay
peach cobbler's number one so the other
food take and i love this ready for
whatever 43.
there there 42 other people that are
more ready for whatever than he is i
appreciate that because i thought you
were laughing because i said whatever no
no
i thought that was gonna be like the
running
show who was it what was the other one
what was the one you just oh gosh it was
like i don't remember cap on the app or
whatever it was capping on them
ready for whatever 43.
pancakes over waffles all day i don't
care taylor rooks asked me this recently
rank these three pancakes waffles french
toast
and it's the best version of them
um if it's a roscoe's waffle for those
that are familiar with los angeles gotta
rock with the roscoe's waffle i feel
like waffles are more elegant than
pancakes and like french toast delicious
but it's just like leftover bread that
wow
i sometimes feel though that a perfect
french toast when it has like some of
the egg wash still like very it really
hits it's a slapper but i agree with you
and i i have to did he say pancakes or
waffles
he said pancakes waffles are elegant
belgian waffles like i don't even know
how they got in there
i feel like they stole it from africa
some do from belgium absolutely right
i'm taking these back to 100
that's that's how it goes we just saw
that with the chocolate right going back
you know what i mean
sorry belgian like belgium like i'm just
letting you know like your waffles could
be taken so which country do you think
it was from uh mr roscoe so i feel like
they originated
in los angeles
and somebody else just took right now oh
man i feel bad we just keep throwing
this up with zion which one zion and he
would go all three sorry zion you can't
do that what kind of po boy is that
though is it catfish is it shrimp shrimp
but i don't see the shrimps i see one
long yeah i see one long strip of meat
you're right it's like a filet of fish
po boy do you think when zion eats a
shrimp po boy and a shrimp falls out he
goes ooh and then trigger
zion to me seems like a guy that i would
never try to stop i got to stop this is
not funny this isn't funny yeah but he's
a guy i would never trifle with and it's
like if he's like the same thing
okay
okay stop adam stop why did they make
this why do they do it racist that man
has done nothing but perform for you
guys he's heard okay man live they have
in the back tabulated
the scores of the five take masters and
we have come down to the final two
the final two was
the celtics
and our
guy
uh what was but who was the guy that did
the celtics caleb caleb pete kpj kpj
and
the heat goran druggage sleeper cell
rage against twit so congratulations
clap it up
fight to the death now
one on one whoever misses the most shots
wins and we have them they were patient
enough to be with us the entire time and
so let's bring in our man with the
celtic stake the young legend himself
my man how are you first of all say your
name say where you live tell people
where they can follow you
uh my name is caleb p jordan um i live
in mississippi actually and you can
follow me on youtube caleb p jordan you
know caleb with a k p jordan follow me
on youtube i actually just dropped the
video like five seconds ago really wow
okay yeah he's smart heart how's your
sister doing
oh is she doing good she's actually in
school i had to leave school today no i
see you should have pulled her out with
you bro you going you climbing to the
top that's a that's a free day from
school
you're right all right caleb p jordan
you heard us breaking down your video
what did you take away from our analysis
um more of a just being uh original i
understand i got your point about being
original uh you hear a lot about uh
people talking about the celtics
actually last night on nba on tnt kenny
beach who's a youtuber he actually
talked about the celtics was like oh man
so you hear a lot of people bring in
their scenarios about the celtics so
it's like seeing the other guys talk i'm
like man they did they didn't talk about
things that people on tv really don't
talk about so were you angry at me when
i lowered your score be honest no no no
sorry i knew i i was good i was good he
just goes he's understandable bro i like
this guy no he called me sir when i did
this but i was like bro just call me
josiah it made me feel oh but well he's
tons of respect good dude hard worker
like i said like i told you when i was
on your joint you're gonna be the future
of this game so keep grinding better
takes though pick better teams of
rockwood all right so caleb i've just
decided on the spot
that in order to figure out who is going
to win
i'm going to give you
20 seconds to think of your best food
take and that will be the competition so
i'll let you think about it right now
again spicy creative
confrontational you can something maybe
we've said uh so but i kind of want it
on the spot to see how you can freestyle
with your takes so i've now vamped for
about 15 seconds whenever you're ready
give us your best food take
wow i'm actually ready i'm actually
ready
hear me out right here i've seen this a
lot on twitter i have a question for you
two guys right here
our bonus wings wings no and then what
is your take give us your take
they're not wings they're not wings and
the reason why i said this tank is
because everybody who i argued and
actually at work i wanted to clock out
of work earlier a couple weeks ago for
my saying that there are wings the fact
that he said that i wanted to write
myself up because that's just that's
just don't say that again but they're
not wings if they don't have any bones i
mean yeah they don't have any bones and
you can pick it up with a knife and a
fork they're they're chicken nuggets
simple wow that's a really good take i
was gonna say they're closer to
meatballs like
meatballs no no give me a bone she like
you know
and internet please don't take that
boss caleb pete jordan everybody caleb
stay on the line that was really good he
did that on the line which that also
means that our next contestant kind of
has a leg up because he kind of knows
he's had more time so i'm not going to
give him as much time rage against twit
the speedster goran dragach is a sleeper
agent let's welcome it now rage against
twit
rage you heard our critiques uh i
believe in the earliest round you were
the highest scorer you have a look on
your face like what am i waiting for
right now what is your response to
everything you've heard thus far today
i mean first of all i feel like there's
a lot of home cooking right here i mean
josiah you knew the kid before you came
on i mean you know i appreciate it he's
a young buck you know he seemed very
proper it seemed like you know i'm gonna
give him a follow after this but josiah
i mean this is like home cooking i mean
you guys are setting me up there's a lot
i'm glad that he came on with the
celtics tape because there's a lot of
anti-heat propaganda going on and adam
lefko you're a part of it as well your
network okay the other day went and put
the memphis game versus the celtics over
the nets heat game they change that game
that was my decision
i didn't agree with that
again i didn't agree with that i didn't
agree with that um how is this actually
this goron draggage take a take that
you've actually had for a while or when
you saw us say give us your takes you're
like let me come up with one real quick
let me cook up a take
well you know
you know there's a lot of hype going of
gorn drivers possibly coming you know it
was a long shot kind of him coming in
and you know when you finally see him in
miami you're like you know what this is
probably gonna happen and the fact that
he went to uh the nets i was like man
that's an l but then i thought about a
little beat there but i'm like this is
this is probably a bigger plan by pat
riley oh so you really believe this i
love it
i mean i mean
why do they call him the godfather if
he's not doing golf other like things um
you have a question for him before i go
to food no i'm i mean i think you got
the highest score in the first round so
it definitely was yeah so you're the
favorite right you are the favorite
and honestly i believe in crazy
propaganda and conspiracy and all types
of stuff so i would say that that's very
well in the range of possibilities like
dragon and riley are texting each other
memes and stuff do you think that guru
dragach has a fake tooth filled with
cyanide just in case he gets found out
you know what kevin durant's like
something's fishy
the fake joint uh all right what is give
us your spiciest food take where do you
want to take this rage well first i mean
first of all pancakes overrated second
of all boneless wings are wings because
if it's a chicken product it's a wing
i'm sorry i just have to i have to just
it is it's wings
what if it's a chicken leg
wow and just like that oh no hold on
hold on was that going to be your food
take or did you have a different one no
i'm just trying to respond to what was
going on in the show you know i've been
listening here for a while so wow
pancakes they're not they're just like
an everyday type of deal like it's not a
big deal to get pancakes when you pull
out that waffle machine you put that mix
in an appropriate amount of cinnamon all
that goodness spray it down make sure
you don't get the janky waffle that
wasn't poured properly it's a lot of
goes into it any final comments rage
against twitt before we we put you aside
and josiah and i figure out who wins
um
heaton five
oh eighteen five eight and five all
right spicy that's gonna take them off
the screen take them off that was the
spiciest okay thank you rage against
twit i can't look at his face i can't
deliberate in front of him okay take
masters put him in the waiting room
so
i will say of the two takes
i like to rage against twits more
clearly we gave it a higher score yeah
i thought that in the freestyle round
our guy kpj
delivered a beautiful soliloquy 20
seconds felt like on the dot
on wings off the top of his head
i was a little bit disappointed against
rage against twit right there i like
that he went counter to you but then you
hit him with the chicken leg and it was
stumped stumped
chicken legs are not wings stumped it's
like impossible burgers that is not a
bird you're a flats only guy
straightforward i get it you already
know okay um
and and so i'm torn because in the
freestyle round
i feel like kpj won but in the take
master round i thought it was rage
against twit
and so what i'm going to do
as a trained professional
is to let you make the decision i knew
you're going to do that to me is to put
all the pressure on josiah johnson see
if i pick caleb i get accused of home
cooking right but if i go a rage against
but
his wing take
but are we going to really boil this
down to a wing tank but i do like the
gorn dragon sleeper cell because it
could be possible he definitely looks
like the type that you know his only
allegiance
audrey i just want you to say one name
in my ear and i'm i'm not gonna yeah we
just want to know who you think our our
amazing producer she's saying so much
pressure
i like ties okay
did you hear what she picked i didn't
okay
sh
she is picking goran draggage sleeper
cell rage against twit if we can blame
audrey i think we'll do that i think so
too she's pregnant you can't get mad at
her congratulations rage against twit
go you won let me get back on the
podcast though let me get back on the
podcast and and kpj i just want you to
know that you are the man you are an
up-and-comer uh you killed it in the
freestyle round but the rage against
twit take was too good rage against twit
you have the floor uh anything you want
to say to the thousands of people that
will undoubtedly follow you after this
experience
i mean follow this closely i feel like
there's gonna be a lot of thing pieces
going forward it's not really gonna
happen soon my prediction like we're
going to have so you know going dragon's
going to make it look good in the
beginning make it look good but wait
until you get to the playoffs it's going
to be he's going to put he's going to
put him in predicament he's going to
beat some bad passes probably give up an
easy pat you know easy layup to pass it
to ben simmons just watch what's going
forward towards the playoffs rage
against twit congratulations you are our
first winner of take masters uh audrey
do we still have the other contestants
on the line or have they dropped off in
furious anger
caleb let's throw kayla about rage
against to it congratulations caleb uh
we need to talk to you again because we
love you uh congratulations on being a
finalist and uh where can people follow
you again i feel really bad because
you're young
where can they follow you at caleb p
jordan on youtube
[Music]
you already know yes sir caleb join on
youtube k-a-l-e-b p jordan like michael
jordan this is your origin story now
okay
years from now we will face off
and you will end me and that's just how
it goes he's gonna be like yeah i lost
take masters after i dominated this dude
in the freestyle round and i never let
him live it down uh what were the names
of the other people that performed i
know ryan flossy flossy
he was philosophy big country big love
country thank you guys your takes were
really good everybody in the app giving
the takes thank you so much this was
take masters and we want to do this for
other events whether it's the nfl
whether it's
we're gonna have to do a food one by
itself for sure uh do you have a meme to
represent how you feel about what we
just experienced i do not because i
didn't have time and you caught me off
guard but i will say i appreciate you
guys anytime i get to come out to
atlanta i got the full recline on the
plane it was amazing had some peanuts
and almonds and a nice snack selection
they served peanuts on an airplane yeah
we're back wow they have pistachios too
but i'm not a pistachio guy pandemic's
really over pandemic is ooh that full
recline so appreciate y'all pulling up
thank you to the crew and everybody
everybody did an amazing job even the
sneeze
well played it was a well-timed sneak
well-placed knees top 10 sneeze that
i've ever experienced in my life i'd
normally do that to tell people to rap
like sneeze all right
wrap it up
uh thank you for being here
i want to get all emotional but i hope
we do this again so i'm not going to
like say
king josiah we're getting it you're the
man uh lefko here thanks to everybody in
the app i'll just piggyback on all your
thank yous thank you to the amazing
production crew that whipped this up out
of nowhere you guys were killing it with
the green screen this was a lot of fun
and if you have takes
be on the lookout when we are calling
out for the videos 20 seconds and this
is your chance to shine we are gonna
remember all of these takes and if they
hit we will celebrate you this has been
take masters i'll actually later
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]